Скрипка має чотири струни.
Гуцульські цимбали —
я робив по 7 струн, то було 189 струн.
4 і 189 — є різниця.
Коли мій син почав грати на цимбалах,
їх було важко дістати.
Я звертався до багатьох, були якісь цимбали,
які мені не подобалися.
Тому я вирішив самостійно змайструвати
цимбали для свого сина. Так і зробив.
Спочатку вчився робити гуцульські цимбали.
В Шепоті мене навчав Василь Червнявський.
Він мене навчив багатьох речей.
Взагалі, я добре знав креслення.
Тому відразу намагався робити цимбали самостійно.
Це початок нових цимбалів.
Вони схожі на маленькі гуцульські,
лише угорського ладу.
Тут я роблю цимбали в Путилів,
що у Чернівецькій області, у музичну школу для дітей.
Це називається спідня дека в цимбалах.
Тут вирбельбанки.
Або, як називають по-гірському, «баби».
Потрібні ось такі два вирбельбанки.
Ось...
Потім тут складається рама...
Ось такі два бруски,
і тут повинні бути кілочки з обох сторін.
Зверху верхня дека.
Ось таку верхню деку потрібно.
Верхню деку можна виготовити із цього матеріалу.
Зі смереки.
Ці частини треба склеїти.
Тут все сходиться по отворах —
ось.
Кількість заготовок залежить від ширини інструменту,
і скільки таких частин потрібно склеювати.
Це на великі цимбали для шунди, для верхньої деки.
А тут буде маленька дека.
Ось такі «кобилки», підставки.
Підставки називаються «кобилки»,
а так, це підставка для струн.
Ось такий початок таких цимбалів.
Я зробив 33 гуцульських цимбалів. Саме гуцульських.
Є в мене в Канаді одні цимбали,
є двоє у Польщі, є у Німеччині.
Робив для Ворохти, Яремче.
У Микуличині також є мої цимбали,
і у Верховині, у Космачі.
Мене не називають цимбалістом,
бо я сам не граю на них.
Проте дуже багато людей мене знають.
Робота вимагає точності.
Гуцульські цимбали, приблизно,
потрібно робити протягом двох місяців.
Потрібно знайти гарний кучерявий явір.
Необхідно знати, коли його варто зрубати.
Переважно з нього ми
виробляємо скрипки і цимбали.
Дуже важко знайти такий кучерявий явір.
Потім треба його порізати на пилорамі
на дошки, на бруски...
Випилювати треба на деталі...
На спідні дошки потрібно знайти широкий явір.
Зараз можна використовувати
клей для таких дощок.
Спідню деку можна клеїти, як верхню.
А колись ми не клеїли гуцульські цимбали...
Шукали такий явір, щоб була ціла дошка.
Над рештою потрібно працювати самостійно:
потрібно робити деталі, знати креслення.
Знати, що треба зробити...
Гуцульські цимбали й угорські —
це майже два різних інструменти.
Гуцульські мають один крій цимбалів,
бо вони мають центральну кобилку (підставку)
і другу басову, та й все.
А тут, в угорських цимбалах, — більше підставок.
На них можна більше зіграти...
Тут є більше октавів.
Тут зовсім інша сила, яка тягне, і тому потрібно
докласти зусиль, щоб поставити рами у великих цимбалах.
Варити...
Дуже тягне...
Якщо погано поставити раму —
цимбали не триматимуть стрій, та й усе.
Потрібно мати дуже багато навичок, щоб робити цимбали —
треба бути не лише майстром.
Потрібно бути і ковалем, і зварювальником...
І все робити...
Треба теж бути трішки музикантом.
[грають на цимбалах та скрипці]
Це мій подарунок на 18 років від батька.
Особливого дару до
майстрування цимбалів я не маю.
Але строї...
Струни мотаємо разом, я допомагаю йому натягувати...
Але до таких дерев'яних робіт
у нього немає схильності.
Хоча, можливо, колись і буде.
[грає на цимбалах]